good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this
meeting of cabinet
uh do we have any apologies for absent
sam
we have apologies from councillor
o'donnell
thank you on
uh disclosures of interest do i have any
disclosures of interest
we'll take that as a no
minutes
to confirm and sign
the minutes of the meeting held on 25th
of october and the 1st of november
is everyone comfortable with the minutes
thank you
so moving on to
matters to be referred to council
item four notice of motion universal
credit cuts
uh
councillor barker
thank you councillor jefferson um you're
if you turn to page 11 very briefly 11
to 14
you'll find a summary report which is
what was requested in response to this
notice of motion
um
and it was proposed by councillor
together on the 18th of october
and we have considered the impact we are
considering the impact of the removal of
the universal credit allowance
the scheme finished uh in october the
6th on october 6th
anecdotally because i helped run a food
bank
and have asked plenty of
all our attendees what impact has had on
them
that there hasn't been a huge impact
which is has surprised me and i'm sure
councillor peter geller can say
something different on that
um and i wouldn't i never want to sound
harsh on these things but the point was
that the 20 pound uplift
in the universal credit was only there
for a temporary period
largely to cover um the fact that more
people would be at home than out and
about um during covid essentially
that's now been reversed um and
to my deep joy if you look at one point
1.8
um the changes have finally been brought
in reducing the amount
um
the taper
from
63p to 55p per pound
earned which is keeping an extra 8p
might not sound much but
that was the level at which the center
for social justice um first recommended
that um it should be set for universal
credit and there is
not unadulterated joy amongst everybody
that it has gone to that but most of us
think that it is a lot more reasonable
the main point i'd like to make is that
we work with the lga
uh
item 1.16
you'll see
their comment on what's going on and how
much effort the lga will be putting into
pressurizing the government
um particularly on the household support
fund and the other funds that come
through county
um
and the bottom line with this
is
as you'll see in my own comment at 3.1
universal credit is a national scheme
uh we have limit we can't change it we
can't bring in our own
version we don't have a pot of cash to
add to it
um and all that we can affect is to work
with the lga and
um through as we've put here our
existing channels to lobby
for
um the best solution possible
for people um
so
it's my suggestion to cabinet that we
reject the proposals in the notice of
motion
with a heavy heart and not
um being callous but because actually
there is nothing we can do other than
lobby thank you
thank you chair i just wanted to make up
an observation because obviously
thank you very much for this very
comprehensive
report i notice in 1.13
um we have 4230
of the claimants who were not in
employment
um i happened to take a look at
job websites over the weekend
and i i know talking to a number of
people who run businesses there is a
huge it's there is terribly difficult
there's a huge recruitment difficulty
in for both part-time
unskilled workers and it was interesting
to note on the total jobs website that
for stratford-upon-avon
upon avon not on avon alone there were
1362 vacancies
for
people in hospitality retail care
and i just wonder whether we should be
doing trying to do more to encourage
those who are not in employment
to
seek opportunities appreciate some of
these opportunities may may clash with
child care arrangements but i just
wonder whether we should be doing more
of your focus to encourage more people
back into employment
thank you councillor paris some very
good points councillor pemberton
thank you leader just to pick up on
councillor parry's point
members of cabinet and those watching
the meeting may recall that
excuse me
apologies
councillor jennings
organized as part of the mop fair
celebrations
unemployment fair and i understand that
the results of that exercise are to come
forward fairly shortly
and that if that has proven to be
a successful
way forward
then i think that there could well be
other opportunities potentially for us
to host in this building some form of
regular job fair
because the reality is that
we should as a society
help every single person that we can
to be able to
live without having to live on benefits
uh there are clearly people who cannot
but those who we can help into the
workplace and work is
good for people
not just from an economic perspective
but from a social perspective from a
health perspective from a well-being
perspective
so if there is anything that we can do
and this may well be and i would look
forward to
an early
analysis of what impact that event had
and if we can then move that forward i
would be
fully supportive of that and i doubt
there is a member of cabinet who would
not thank you
councillor barker you wish to come in
yes i just i just wanted to come in on
that and i don't know
i'd love councillor dennis to come in on
the uh what he's been doing i
um in the past i have run job clubs and
one of the things that i have found
really
important
is
encouraging people back into work
and helping to instill some confidence
because it doesn't take much time out of
work for people to lose that confidence
and
again it's something i do via food bank
when we have people who
want to get jobs if i know somebody
who's got one i'll
push them in that direction introduce
them and that just that confidence of
having somebody else there
really does help so i i completely
endorse
um what cancer pemberton's saying that
we as a council can be helping with that
um and totally with uh what council
jennings is going to do with his
roving job for councillor jennings
thank you very much um
the results have come in on it
um we got
um from the feedback from those who
attended
the job fair uh 10 of them said that
they managed to recruit from that which
is uh
which is a tremendous success if you
look at how many
um how much money was spent on the event
which was a very small amount um it just
took a lot of effort from all of those
involved
um from
from
those who supported the
support of the event
um from
the magazines from the actual playhouse
from the staff here
from the offices
and a lot of work went into it and
say 10
is a
tremendous success
however that means that ninety percent
of the jobs weren't filled
and uh
i'm being talking to various groups
after this and
and particularly the voluntary job
sector as well very keen to get involved
because obviously that makes a big
difference
um to
to society so i'm at the moment going
through and talking
uh and looking at setting up something
which is a ongoing
um almost fortnightly quarterly
voluntary job fair newsletter which will
go out to the parishes i'm also looking
at incorporating something else into
other jobs as well
um so permanent jobs so there is there
is a lot going on at the moment behind
the scenes
thank you councillor jennings and i
think we all applaud your initiative in
actually uh
starting the jobs fair
uh councilman junit
um can i just uh read directly off the
citizens advice
network at the webpage which states that
one-third of the people affected are
already in employment
so these are not people that are out of
work at all there's one-third
are in
employment
and of those
um over a half have family and children
as well
and that's directly off the citizens
advice bureau so it's not people that
are out of work
thank you councillor june
councillor pertiguella you requested to
speak do you wish to do so now
so um first of all thank you for giving
me the opportunity to come and speak
since the motion was submitted the
report by the council on changes to
cover the 19 financial support measure
measures that was circulated to all
councillors and and published we know
that not only
the universal credit uplift ended at the
beginning of october but also the farlow
scheme and the extended notice period
required to evict residential tenants
the 20 pounds universal threated uplift
represented a lifeline
often the only means by which families
did not get into depth of poverty
it has been a very good benefit
entitlement and with rising energy cost
and rises in food prices the council on
report states that many individuals and
families will find it increasingly
difficult to make ends meet
the district council on report on social
and economic data in the coveted 19
period to april 2021
showed that as stratford or navon
district at the biggest percentage
increase 184 percent
between march 20 and april 21 in local
authority claimant levels of any
authority in the west midlands
in our district we have 8 000 people
nearly 8 000 people claiming universal
credit
in august 20
21 and in the recent background four
thousand uh two 230 of these claimants
were not in employment
now there are several reasons why people
are not in employment
not just because they are currently
looking for job but also for serious
health issues or caring responsibilities
so we need to take that into
consideration as well
the chancellor announcement on the
universal credit taper rate
won't cover what many have already lost
and doesn't make up for the cuts the
taper might give some working families
relief as they will be able to retain
more of their income but in reality the
budget announcement is giving much less
of what the government took away with
the removal of the 20 pounds per week
uplift locally thousands of families and
individuals who are not in work will not
be helped at all
even with the minimum wage increase
because of a rise in the cost of living
as well as national insurance rights the
20 cut the 20
pounds cut we still affect thousands of
residents in our district
a single parent or minimum wage working
part-time still loses 30 pounds a month
per year now i want to direct you to the
resolution foundation review of the
budget
and in here the the
researcher states that the majority of
the households on universal credit will
be worse off as a result of the decision
to take away the 20 pounds per week
uplift and this is despite the chance of
new universal creative measures in the
budget
um
and
so i i and i can quote from the
resolution foundation report which is
published
and three quarters of families on
universal credit we lose more than the
20 cups than the gain from the budget
changes
even if we also take into account the
impact council together can you please
concentrate on
uh the motion as submitted yes so i
noted that the council is already
lobbying the local government
association and i would have thought the
lobbying through the lga is done as a
matter of course
therefore while i seek assurances that
the impact of these cuts which will be
felt in the next in the future months so
they're going to be felt in in the next
you know in the next few months um i
you know that this impact will be
monitored and also how it affects our
our services so i will first of all seek
assurances of that
and then i
urge the cabinet to agree to lobby
directly the government
through a letter outlining our own war
in data
and how this cuts
might have a negative effect on
thousands of our residents and as
counselors we should be a loud voice for
our residents when government decisions
affect them directly
and have an impact on our services so it
is in our gift to lobby the government
directly
and i hope that the cabinet will support
the motion in particular to write to the
department for working pensions the
treasury and our two local mps to state
that the uplift should be reinstated
thank you thank you councillor peter
geller
yes
mr platt
thank you and
just just to answer manuela's points
really um i think we we have to accept
that the 20 pound is gone by the time
the actual motion came to cabinet the
budget had taken place and the 20 pound
change had been um
enacted so i would be incredibly
surprised if that were to be reversed at
some point however i'm taking on all of
your points manuela um
i am already lobbying the dwp in line
with lots of other local authorities
through the lga through the housing
benefit forum through the institute of
revenues and
valuation and also through
any local
consultation that we get
we're dealing in individual cases day in
day out i have regular contact with mary
dunleavy i have regular contact with bob
kelsey at the job centre and we are
desperately trying to help those local
residents where we can
and when there's any consultation coming
out for any welfare scheme i can assure
you that i always complete that
consultation
promptly and and get that in but in
terms of
our response it has to be coming from
all local authorities the the dwp won't
change um the universal credit rules
just for the stratford area so it's it's
a real question of continuing to lobby
where we already do
um and
hoping that in the fullness of time
those changes take place but in terms of
what we can do locally to change
something today or tomorrow or next week
or next month that's
pretty limited um
thank you mr platz and i think you're
absolutely right
the budget's been
the cuts have been made and i can't see
them being reinstated councillor barker
i would just refer us all back to
section 1.8 again because that's the
best we're going to get out of it and
i completely understand that
um there are plenty of people
who are
sick and therefore cannot work and i'm
sure like you
you like me you spend a lot of time
filling in pip applications with people
so there are many
many benefit routes for people to go
down and the same for families but
there isn't a magic money tree no matter
what anybody thinks and that 20 pounds
was going to be temporary it's gone what
we're now trying to do is move forward i
take your point about lobbying
um however
a lot of it goes on and i can assure you
that therese coffee fought
to the nail to get the 20 pounds
um kept in place and she didn't win
against the treasury but
the win has been with the percentage it
with the um
the taper
and for at least for people in work so
um
in total i think we have done all that
we can and i know that mr platts
with his other colleagues who who are in
customer services revs and benefits and
so on they
they do go in quite hard on
because day in day out
he and i and others deal with the really
really difficult cases that make that
can reduce you to tears you know this is
not an inhuman thing that we've got to
find a way of making it work as
efficiently as possible and that's what
we're doing and never fear i will never
stop personally writing letters making
phone calls and what's that messages
thank you councillor barker
councillor kettle
i was just going to draw attention to
paragraph 1.18
which i think where officers have
volunteered to work with the county
council with the distribution of the
um
3.47 million that the county's got uh i
think demonstrates uh officers
commitment to um to try and do the best
for our residents in this district
thank you councillor kettle councillor
junior
i just wonder whether i could also
address um 1.14 uh because i had a
recent case um of somebody who was
trying to access the uh the form that is
referred to there
and because they only had a mobile phone
and were in an area with intermittent uh
reception
they couldn't fill the form in on the
mobile phone uh in the end i did have to
get somebody to ring them back and they
had to and i had to warn them that the
mobile phone was intermittent
and so that they could go through the
form in several stages um which just
illustrates the difficulty um so but
when you talk about the digital strategy
later on i do hope that you'll bear in
mind that sometimes um you know filling
in that online form that has got 33
questions in total to get the help that
you need is not always easy even even if
you can actually have a reason for the
converted counselling thank you
mr platts then council of pemberton and
then i think we draw this to a close
down if you want to go first
i was just really going to suggest that
this sans
it's not a con it sounds like a
conversation for councillor junior to
have with mr platz to help support that
person um
we all have a myriad of examples where
for lots of different reasons the thing
don't work i think solving the problem
is probably the more important thing and
i would urge counselors units to liaise
with mr platz
two two very quick points actually i was
just going to say that we do go that
extra mile and we do provide the
telephone service for those residents
who can't do it online or the councils
don't offer that facility but we do and
just to add to councillor jennings's
point and i know manuela was on the
training last week in terms of job
creation
the additional funding that we got from
the government for the business rate
grants that we're working with the
growth up with one of the main criteria
is that those grants are awarded to
businesses who are creating part-time
and full-time jobs in the district right
across the district and they're not jobs
that are just for a few weeks through
the christmas period they're sustainable
and they're building back for the future
thank you
thank you mr platt so councillor barker
am i right in thinking you proposed uh
to reject the proposals in the notice of
motion yes i did
can i have a second
thank you councillor james
uh all those in favor of the proposal
thank you members of cabin
moving on developing a digital strategy
for south warwickshire councillor
cargill
thank you leader thank you members
right uh this paper sets out the vision
for the future i.t system for both
organizations and that's irrespective
of whether a full merger goes ahead on
the 13th or not
if accepted the strategy will be
implemented over a number of years
as laid out in the previous papers on
transformation
core to the strategy is the provision of
improved services through
digitalization
uh for um and
i should say pick up
what's going to happen now that can
spark is going to pick up this point
um for our customers but not to exclude
anyone from accessing the system a
pertinent point with cancer juno
the other major thrust here is to make
the operation organization more
efficient and therefore more cost
effective
there are a number of themes to the
document i'll pick a few out
simplicity a good system is a simple way
to operate we all have had experience
with complex forms on the web
and on websites our goal is to make our
systems as easy to use as possible
inclusive
a customer centric system would be
failing if it did not cater for all of
the letters to access it the intention
is that irrespective of how you access
the system the experience will be
enhanced to that currently available
and collaboration is vital that we work
with our communities and businesses and
how best to serve them
and obviously
that their input is vital in this way
and innovation
uh is vital for any organization
unfortunately change such as what we're
proposing tends to happen once and then
tends to stop
continuous improvement therefore is a
worthy goal through smaller
iterative steps as opposed to major
structural changes
importantly innovation can come from
within and this is to be encouraged if
after all our offices are best placed to
come with solutions on how to best
improve the systems that they actually
operate
the to achieve the best and most
efficient use of the system when fully
implemented it's vital that members
fully support it and act as digital
ambassadors promoting it to their
residents
leader i recommend this paper to the
cabinet thank you
thank you councillor cargill councillor
pemberton
uh thank you chairman and leader um i
just i i welcome the draft to digital
digital strategy
and i would urge members of cabinet
and those around the table to remember
that the clues in the title it's a
strategy
so we're not here to debate
the detail
are we going to use azure are we going
to use salesforce crm i think what we're
talking about is setting
a direction
um
i'm sorry
i i'd really just want to say that you
know we're here to talk and make a
decision upon a strategy so we'll talk
the recommendation is accepting a
strategy that there's a program
initiated and there's a governance
structure adopted for the transformation
program i think those points two and
three as we go through it are the points
where the where the devil which may well
be in the detail is actually for i'm
struggling to see anything at the
strategic level that said that that is
missed or we shouldn't do uh as far as
the strategy is concerned um
and i and i would urge any member of
this council to uh who wants to get into
the devil of the detail to use the
transformation program and the
governance structures to influence that
particular debate and i'm happy to
support the recommendation
thank you council of pemberton i think
you're absolutely right
uh there will no doubt be an awful lot
of detail
i think the other thing is that
the success
of the merger and in actually making the
savings that we need
is dependent
on it
it's one of the biggest risks that's
been identified in the merger
and i will draw people's attention to
646.
it's a fundamental program of change
that will ultimately benefit everyone
and exclude no one
so
uh
i'm assuming councillor cargill you
proposed it and you seconded it
councillor pemberton so i've now got
councillor kettle
and then councillor junit
um and absolutely support what my
colleagues have said i would just um
request as the strategy develops
that um
we have
a
a slight um there's a caution about um
trying to deliver a blue sky
uh it
salesmen are wonderful at telling us it
will solve the world
uh and um it'll be very easily installed
and don't worry all you have to do is
put a disk in your
hard drive it'll all work
obviously that dates me something
because we don't have hard drives we
don't have this sorry sorry what's a
disk
but um it is absolutely critical to
define what we want to achieve
and work to make sure that that target
is achievable
rather than look to um i say rebuild the
world with blue sky and i think it's
very very clear to make sure within that
strategy we have achievable aims not
wished for aims
thank you councillor kettle a cautionary
point
and having had some considerable
experience with it departments
i would never ever say that they tend to
over promise and under deliver
councillor harvey then councillor jew
thank you mr chairman
um by your leave i wonder if i could
invite
mr elkinson to uh have a word i gather
that all right i assume i think it's a
reasonable assumption that this paper
has
been long in the gestation there's a lot
of hard work and thought gone into it um
i wonder if you could just explain drop
on your previous experience elsewhere
which um
would lead us to have uh confidence and
be inspired by the the work you've
produced
not putting you on the spot at all mr
elkins
no okay um so in terms of my experience
in previous digital transformations um i
used to work in newcastle in the line
for a council before before i started
here
um and one of the last things that i was
involved in before leaving was starting
off their digital program and starting
their transformation program
the work that we did it started off in
the waste service it was an in-house
service um collected multiple streams
pretty similar to what happens in
stratford uh but it was quite heavily
plagued by the fact that a lot of
a lot of the resource in-house um there
was a lot of manual intervention there
was a lot of conversations between the
front office contact centre and the back
office teams we'd had two previous
iterations of digital systems uh in-cab
systems that
hadn't worked out that have been run by
the the the attempts to be made service
areas themselves
and then we we started
so we started attacking it in a
different way we started looking at it
from the perspective of what about what
are the customers of the council trying
to do when they interact with with
customer services what is what is it
that the waste service needs from the
front office teams as well
the net outcome of that
we totally
altered the way that that service area
works we introduced automation across
the board we use rules-based checking
for when so say when someone um
checked so they wanted to report a
missed bin rather than ringing through
to the back office and finding out where
the round was or whatever the systems
themselves would check they would work
together um the customer service agents
if it was on the phone they'd just have
to tell the person whether it was they
were going to come back or not
if they were reporting it on the website
it was seamless it was um
it went straight through when we
introduced chargeable garden waste that
was entirely launched that was launched
initially as an online service and it
was just over 80 percent of the the
transactions actually happened entirely
online no one was involved in them
and that sort of that success in that
one area then
sort of spurred on a lot of other areas
to become involved in the digital
transformation program
at the point where i left um the council
were we just got approval to replace the
council's website with a new new version
which went live a couple of weeks ago
um we had got the revenues and benefits
team working
with the digital team to redevelop their
um approach to work which again has
resulted in some significant
improvements they've had a massive
online take up um all of that work had
started and and was was well underway at
the point um
that i left so
the way that we've structured the the
strategy for um
for stratford for south for south
warwickshire we've looked at um
targeting programs which are kind of
fundamental to the way that the council
services operate so things like uh
looking at crm systems to improve the
visibility of how transactions go as
they move through the council we're
looking at um you know very
i'm going to say simple changes that we
can make that will have a massive impact
on the way that residents can interact
with our services and the capabilities
of our services to then deliver for the
residents for the businesses for for the
communities in south oracle so this will
be um i mean again the governance
structure that's being proposed will
make sure that there is an oversight of
everything that is happening within the
programme that the members members
you're involved in what's going on you
have visibility of how we're progressing
we will set up milestones in each of the
programs every program will be every
suggestion that is in here will be
accompanied by business case which fully
explains what the council will get out
of it what is needed to be invested what
the benefits will be um and they they
will be scrutinized the same as anything
else so you you can have confidence that
when we start on this process we will
work through it piece by piece we'll
start off with the basics we'll get
those right and then we'll we'll move on
we intend to work with service areas we
intend to work with our customers we
intend to work with the businesses that
we serve to shape the way that our
digital services go forward and i think
council of cargill already said this but
there's no with this strategy there's no
intention to exclude any resident it's
not like we're going to stop people from
ringing us or we're going to stop people
coming in face to face we'll be looking
at trying to work to reduce digital
exclusions obviously we know that that
is a problem within the districts um so
again there are lots uh there's lots of
work that's already gone on within other
councils that we can learn from there's
lots of exemplar projects that we can
take and we can adapt to the to the
stratford and the warwick area and we
can we can really make this into
something that will work for to the
benefit of of our residents and our
communities for everybody within the
south oracle area
thank you mr elkington councillor junit
and can i um can i actually
say thank you for to help the person who
produced this strategy
because one of the things that we're
going to what i'm going to be asking for
is a review and a report back on
progress because when you look at some
of the things that are
the starting point
despite the fact that the district
council support signed a local digital
declaration in october 2018
the accessibility of the website
is less than 70 percent compared to
99.9.9 percent for warwick district
council
19 of council tax player
council tax players are registered for
warwick's online revenue and benefit
system
only just over one percent take up for
stratford so if you bear that in mind
that there is uh there are problems and
the problems are nice and clearly spelt
out in the document
and they should they should be actually
center of anything that reports back it
says that the quality of service
delivery is inconsistent integration is
difficult there's a real duplication of
functionality which by its nature means
that each council is paying for
solutions more than once even before the
merger has begun so please make sure
that every single one of those
criticisms is properly addressed and
when the report comes back we don't want
as counselors necessarily to know which
kind of i.t system is brought in i come
from a family of 100 people who work in
i.t and i still don't want to know every
single detail of every single system i
want to know whether it works whether
it's accessible whether it's
serves the residents of the area well
and that resident that i referred to
earlier
on a mobile phone with intermittent
service can also get the the service
that service that there's equality so
that if you've got problems with your
eyesight you can you can um you can
access so please that the i just think
that this report is uh the actual
strategy is immensely useful
but please refer to it and make sure
that it's addressed thank you thank you
councillor junior
i think i would point out
that if one looks at page 23 on that
document you'll see that only 36 percent
of properties in stratford on irvine had
access to gigabit broadband
availability in warwick was 67.5
uh average download speeds were 25
faster in warwick
uh
just over a thousand properties across
south warwickshire geography have
connections which are slower than two
megabits
and i mean this is one of the problems
we've actually got that our digital
infrastructure in south warwickshire
sorry in stratford-on-oven district is
not ideal councillor cargill
thank you absolutely right and so we
have been pressing for for a long time
they've even got 5g in warwick
so yes we are way behind the times and
interestingly
the digital infrastructure board meeting
i attended the other week
uh it was interesting that again the the
urban areas will be far better served
for for for uh
internet et cetera broadband uh i'll
just pick up the points that cancer
junior has been making if i may
this
this is a
an incisive document it looks at all the
bad points and it's trying to highlight
them and say this is where we need to
improve
so we accept that
it's in the document that's what it's
there for and yes there will be
governance yes we'll be over overseeing
these things so i don't find that
personally a a a negative i think this
is a positive it's saying where we do
need desperate to improve and service
delivery obviously we all want more
people to use the digital um method of
communicating with the with the
organization simply because it's more
cost effective it's quicker and it's a
it's a far better environment so
it is there it's there and that's what
we're looking to try to achieve
and i think to return to councillor
pemberton's original point this is about
a strategy
not actually getting into the details
so
unless anybody's got any more issues on
strategy counselor kettle
um the other side of acquiring a system
is paying the bill
and i.t systems can
for my own experience run away with
enthusiasm
to escape the budget limitations that
have been set by those who have to pay
those bills
um can you reassure us that
as the strategy goes forward that
part of that strategy includes
a method of reining back
the enthusiasm for
it companies to add on bits and pieces
which we then pay for that weren't in
the original budget
absolutely so everything every project
that we do within the strategy will have
a specification for it we'll start off
with a business case that explains what
we what we need to spend what our
investment will be what we're going to
get back in return we will project
manage each of those projects to make
sure that it doesn't creep out of scope
if there are any anomalies with
with add-ons that mysteriously make
their way out we will challenge
suppliers on those and if again we will
keep these projects under review if they
deviate from the plan outside of an
agreed tolerance and that will bring
that back to the government structure to
report back on it so we will absolutely
endeavor with all of the projects to
stay on track to stay on budget and and
not to not to let the price tag run away
councillor pemberton and then councillor
shenton
thank you leader
so with a strategy there's a
transformation program there's a
governance structure and we have an
overview and scrutiny committee that
um
has the opportunity to review any
aspects of the operation of this
organisation is anybody in this room
seriously suggesting that any strategy
is not going to have milestones he's not
going to have review points it's not
going to have check marks i'm not sure
we really need to be told at that level
we've got a strategy there are going to
be checkbox that is just
straightforward strategic planning and
thinking i think we do need to accept
and let our officers who are
professionals build a strategy
with milestones
with check marks with reporting back
with appropriate budgeting and budget
budget monitoring counselor kettle um
i'm not sure we necessarily need to be
telling them how to do that
i i don't imagine mr elkington would
really want that level of um
that level of management by by elected
members thank you
councillor shelton
fine thank you in that case counselor
cargill you've proposed the
recommendations on page 15 council of
pemberton you i believe seconded it
so the reality is can i have your
approval for the recommendations
one two three on page 15.
thank you members of cabinet
now in a slight change to the order
given that the treasury management uh
strategy mid-year review 21
to 21 it says
is a matter to be referred to counsel
uh councillor harvey
thank you leader yes 21-22
this paper is presented because it forms
part of the monitoring process for which
members are responsible
it fulfills a requirement under the
cipher code practice on treasury
management
the seven areas addressed by this report
are set out in paragraph 1.1
on page 88 of the papers
the traditional bulk of the paper has
been provided in appendix 1 which
reviews the economic environment during
the relevant period which has been
overshadowed by the continued disruptive
global economic impact
of the kovit-19 pandemic and the ways in
which and the extent to which the major
economies around the world have
recovered or not
the implications for the council's
finances is that for the foreseeable
future it will be operating against the
background of an economy where inflation
is expected to rise to about five
percent in
2022 driven by supply chain disruptions
imbalances in energy markets and wage
and salary increases as employees and
their trade unions seek to maintain
their real living standards
given that the bank rate has been set by
the mpc at 0.1 in march 2020 and has
remained unchanged ever since
there's only one direction in which
interest rates can go in the face of
increasing inflationary
pressures some forecasters expect bank
rate to rise in 2022 to 1
and to rise further in 2023 to 1.5
to put such forecasts into some
historical context
bank rate has been one percent or lower
for nearly the past 12 years that's
since february 2009
in the 10 years prior to 2009
bank rate varied for most of that decade
between three and a half percent
and six percent
even if bank rate does rise to 1.5
percent therefore by historical
standards this will still see interest
rates at relatively modest levels
table 1 on page 89 sets out the
council's revised capital expenditure
for the current year
the table accurately records that as at
the end of the first half of the year
september 2021
there's been a near doubling of planned
capital expenditure from
10.25 million that's the original
estimate of
roughly five and a half million plus the
delayed expenditure of roughly 6.7
million
to a total of 19.35 million
the picture has changed and will change
further during the year
the four and a half million pounds
included within the 7.6 million pounds
for environmental and operational
services in relation to the financing of
refuse vehicles has now been agreed to
be undertaken by warwick district
council
and the one and a half million pounds
set against the deputy chief executive
relates to the financing of the
riverside project which will be
reimbursed in due course by the coventry
and warwickshire
lab
the remaining increase in capital
expenditure of 3.1 million pounds
relates to the purchase of additional
equipment as a result of the council's
contract with slm for the management of
its leisure centers
paragraph 1.7 reports that the yield
from the council's investment portfolio
of some 34 million pounds was broadly in
line with budgeted level whilst
paragraph 1.9 illustrates how the rates
for borrowing from the public works loan
board have changed during 2021 and their
relationship to gills
the broad messages from the information
in this report therefore are
first
interest rates have been at historically
low rates and can be expected to rise in
2022
although they remain at historically
modest levels
second
movements in financial markets are the
result of perceptions of the impact of
economic changes for example the effect
on supply chains arising from the impact
of covid19 pandemic leading to
volatility in asset prices and yields
and to shortages in energy supplies
leading to cost of living pressures and
resultant levels of higher inflation and
consumer confidence
and third
in the context of continued uncertainty
of financial markets the council's
cautious approach to where and how its
funds are held is well merited i ask
therefore leader this report reviewing
the treasury management of the council's
fund over the first half of the current
financial year be received
thank you councillor harvey uh an
excellent summary of the position
and as you say there is an awful lot of
uncertainty around
and things do seem to change on almost a
daily basis
so i see nobody wishing to comment so
you have proposed the recommendation on
page 87. do i have a second to please
councillor shenton all those in favor
thank you members of cabinet so moving
swiftly on
adoption of revised enforcement policy
and business charter councillor kettle
uh thanks chairman
um
memphis cabinet this is a
um
bringing our enforcement policies
basically in line with uh national
policies uh to ensure that we are
offering the best enforcement policies
to our residents to protect them whilst
not overburdening businesses um with
unnecessary
enforcement um
or unfortunate structure
uh
there are no fundamental changes it is
basically
bringing things into line with current
wording
um
so we have the um
a joint enforcement policy working with
what uh warwick street council
and and that is um
set out in the attached papers
uh food standards food safety
occupational safety health and licensing
um and that that is their type which i
deal with there is a paper in here which
i'm going to ask council parry to pick
up which is relating to the
um
um
planning enforcement side
the other bit that we are introducing
which is a first is the um
a
regulator and business charter across
both stratford and warwick districts and
this is not again imposing any new
restrictions or anything it is setting
out our effectively our working
arrangements with businesses within
uh the stratfor district uh it's an
identical document going in front of
warwick
so i commend the
changes to enforcement policy
i recommend the business charter being
brought forward
uh two cabinet
uh if there are any detailed questions
please do feel free to ask them at which
point i will just
um
step back and let councillor parry pick
up the planning enforcement section
councillor parry
thank you chairman and thank you uh
councillor kettle um i'm delighted to be
bringing forward the local enforcement
planning document which underwent a
consultation
and has been
certainly scrutinized it was certainly
scrutinized extremely well last week at
osc
and i would just like to update cabinet
to advise the government
is still debating
um enforcement planning procedures
within the white paper of the planning
bill that's going to be coming forward
early in the new year of particular
interest
is the fact that there are
it is anticipated
there could be tightening in guidelines
as far as enforcement is concerned which
will be music to everybody's ears in
particular
ministers are debating whether in fact
to introduce retrospective planning
only to those who have perhaps made a
mistake over it which would be
particularly welcomed by all members i
believe in our council um i would also
just like to add that i have written to
nadeem zahawi
following
my session to cabinet at osc last
um last week to particularly lobby
michael gove
to reinforce the importance of
tightening up the enforcement planning
guidelines so what i would like just to
say
is that whilst this is the
updated draft on um local enforcement
planning this could all change on the
back of the
white paper on the planning bill that
comes forward in 2022. that's all i have
further to say
thank you councillor parry councillor
pemberton
uh thank you leader and and indeed the
the planning white paper will loom large
in every member's life uh once it
once it lands uh so undoubtedly a number
of things will be updated i i really
just
i commend this document i know that it's
uh
had a significant uh
element of consultation it's been
thoroughly aired through
the scrutiny process of both authorities
and i'm quite content to
second the recommendation that this goes
to council
as outlined on page 39 of the agenda
papers
thank you councillor pemberton mr perks
do you wish to speak and then councillor
junit
uh thank you leader yes councillor
o'donnell who's given her apology stakes
she couldn't be with us has asked me
just to give a little feedback on behalf
of the overview and scrutiny committee
which i attended earlier in the week um
they wanted to pass on that thanks for
catching perry for a very thorough
performance in your forbearance it was
quite a long session so don't ask me to
pass that on to you
um the comments really relate to the
planning side of the enforcement sort of
paper that we're looking at today
um and i think the general view that
council donald want me to pass on was
that the overview scrutiny committee
felt it was important we focused on
where enforcement enforcement could be
used most effectively the committee
should reluctantly acknowledge some of
the shortcomings that were perceived in
the
legislative framework through in which
we have to operate
and would really support the comments
that council parry has already taken up
about lobbying to sort of make it a more
level playing field
for those um in british planning
legislation and they felt it would be
valuable for a training event for sort
of parish councils and members we should
put together
so so as members are aware of the
framework in which we're operating to
allow them to sort of be more involved
in the process and make sure we use the
resources that we have allocated to
reinforcement as effectively as we can i
think those were the comments unless
some cancer junior doesn't want to enter
this thank you
counselor junit
um yes it it did take up quite a lot of
time at the um at the ovu and scrutiny
um two aspects that were covered one was
the importance of planning uh
enforcement per se
um given that the current national
legislation is very weak i welcome
anything that would strengthen that
at its heart the planning system does
rely on trust
as it stands at the moment but enforcers
provide the backbone of that trust
and um and then that those who do flout
the planning laws and often other laws
at the same time
will be brought to account and there is
the trust that those who strive for high
quality will not be undermined by those
who deliver ill-planned and ill-designed
development
and trust that the high-quality schemes
that achieve planning permission will be
delivered with the same quality and that
planning will deliver what is promised
so that's the kind of what people out
there are expecting
and if the national legislation can be
brought up to um
strengthened but at the same time our
legislation and policy here is
strengthened it will give confidence and
it is confidence that we we ask for
at the ovion scrutiny there was one
other thing that was discussed and that
was the the the fact that the budget
decision on um
to cut
in the planning enforcement
of the the area was not actually
included in this year's budget it was
actually included in next year's budget
and the consultation came
after
the actual
cuts had been already started so it that
exactly also didn't exactly
and confidence
uh so i'd i you know that was what was
also discussed at length at the opium
scrutiny committee uh and i think the
overall scrutiny committee wanted um
assurances a that lobbying would be done
to strengthen national legislation but
also um that
that
that
you know
budget decision would also not be
repeated thank you thank you councillor
junior i'm pretty sure the budget
reductions for enforcement were in this
year's budget can you confirm that
please mr chairman yeah
that
i think the confusion stems from there
was no value assigned to the saving in
2021 and 22 because the cost of
implementing that was being met by the
saving that was being achieved in 21 22
to allow four year savings of 75 000
pounds recurring from 22 23 to be
achieved and it was that 75 000 pound
recurring from 22 23 recurring that's
been allowed for the budget i've
previously discussed massive council
junior and will be absolutely explicit
on future budget papers during
pull out any similar kind of issues so
there's no confusion in
thank you mr brooklyn and just to just
to also confirm there was one single
paragraph that did say a review and a um
it didn't actually say consultation but
it said a review would be on date
undertaken um
at a senior level before any changes
were made to that department
councillor parry
thank you chairman if i could just
explain the changes that have arisen in
the enforcement planning team result
from natural wastage we had a series of
members of staff who retired
which prompted the review
of the consultation and the way of
working i'm delighted to confirm as i
did at osc last week that we now have a
highly a more experienced and more
skilled
member of
team of officers which in in terms of
actual head count res results in half a
full time person less than before but we
have bolstered that up with extensive
more more experience um and extensive
skills and i hope councillor pertiguella
has has welcomed the the assistance of
certainly one of our officers and new
officers who's joined from warwick
district council who i know has been
working very closely with councilman
pertigal on a number of issues on her
award i'd also like to say that actually
during my presentation and
conversations during osc last week i did
highlight that the very comprehensive
training
program that was delivered by um claire
einen um she's currently working on just
reviewing the slide program so that it
can be taken further out to parish
councils and town councils and i did
highlight this as something that was
going to happen so
um we've already we're ahead of the game
on that one thank you thank you
councillor parry
and i think it is good to know that uh
coming down the track from central
government may be a strengthening of
enforcement provisions because i think
we would all welcome that
uh councillor kettle you have proposed
the recommendations on page 39
councillor parry are you second in these
brilliant in that case can i have your
agreement members of council to the
recommendations on page 39
thank you members of council so moving
swiftly on health and well-being south
warwick should place arrangements
councillor barker
um i almost thought that i needed to
declare an interest in this because if
you go through um
and look at the pretty pictures
in our uh
health and well-being plans i i am when
you look at the four-leaf clover
i am now the bottom right hand
uh quadrant of said four-leaf clover and
i've been asked to chair the places and
communities bit
which i'm led to believe by the um
the chief executive of swift is probably
the most complicated bit and i would
agree because of course that is the very
definition of place and how we're going
to deliver it
just as a small preamble we are
within the ics and the place
arrangements
in south forex share going to be
operating somewhat differently to the
others who
potentially look so they could still be
working in an nhs silo or a council silo
whereas we are
being very brave and crossing the
boundaries and prepared to work together
so
watch this space because i'm i'm hopeful
that rolling this out in south warwick's
show will be an exemplar
for
other boards
um it's also for the for the operation
of health and wellbeing boards we have
various of them in towns as well as
across the district and across the
county
um it's a
[Music]
really it's just asking for your um
blessing that we get on with it
and that you will delegate the authority
to me
and the chief executive
to agree any minor amendments the terms
of reference as when they come up
because i'm sure there will be tweaking
to be done
uh all in all it's a really really
exciting reorganization and nhs
reorganization isn't actually something
that
we always get excited about and there's
a lot of it but i really think that it's
gonna work this time so i'd commend it
to you and i commend to you reading the
report to begin to get a handle on what
on earth it all means thank you thank
you councillor pemberton
thank you leader
in my day job i come across complex
off to a bit of dad dancing there with a
tune a cheap executive
you thought you were going to get out of
the room without anything there
after that moment's light relief
councilor pemberton after a moment of
light relief here comes councillor
pemberton thank you leader um yeah in my
day job i deal with people with
significant and complex
care needs
that typically last a lifetime
and
i
have seen across the country
the benefits of the integrated care
system approach that's been rolled out
up and down the land um i'm stunned that
that our colleagues in the north have
failed to address this and i said that
that is you know there are many times
when uh we are compared unfavorably with
other authorities but we are on the side
of the angels with this one um i cannot
commend these recommendations any more
highly icses work really well across the
country they deliver integrated support
from every element of the healthcare
ecosystem whether that's the nhs primary
care secondary care local authorities
charity schedule this is just the way to
go
and the sooner we're on board and
delivering that the better so absolutely
wholeheartedly recommend that and can
see no reason for anything other than
let's get on and do it
thank you council of pemberton a very
interesting perspective from a totally
different direction and very welcome
councillor cargill thank you yeah and
another perspective uh one of my chairs
one of my parishes is uh actually on the
healthwatch um
uh
martin luther charity and i explained
this to him and i showed it to him and
he we went through it and he said i
fully support it it's really good we're
doing it in other ways but i don't
understand it so there you go
thank you thank you council okay
i'm assuming that was a
an endorsement of it
counselor junior it's just a query
please um
will this cover and enable um
rehabilitation and getting people home
because we have in warwickshire i know
we have a dreadful reputation of um
in our system currently about getting
people um home uh with the proper
rehabilitation um
packages etc so i do hope that it does
cover that it undoubtedly doesn't
i i can honestly say
yes like taran's us
because there's
it's on oh sorry was i being quiet oh
dear um
that's absolutely at the top of the
agenda because
apart from anything else it is so much
cheaper to do it's there of course we've
all got the problem
and better for the patient
and we've all got the problem at the
moment of workforce and that is an
absolute nightmare we have that which
means that within hospitals we've got a
flow issue
so people are going in at the front end
probably more than should be and they're
slowed down coming out at the back end
which is a nightmare
um because we haven't got enough carers
and i'm hopeful that we can
maybe that's something that we can look
at when we're talking about jobs
potentially looking at helping to train
or encouraging people into that because
that's
where we lack it and in terms of the
rehabilitation at home um that's working
very much with between the nhs and the
county who provide re-enablement
services which i have to say
are regarded um as really really fine in
comparison to a lot of what you will
find in the rest of the country
can can i just um because apparently at
the warriors she came county council um
cabinet there is a paper that is and it
says in there in 2019 warwickshire
county council will ranked 118
nationally for the indicator on
re-enablement rehabilitation services
with only 1.9 offered reablement
rehabilitation services following
discharge from hospital
thank you councillor junior
i have to say that we're not really
warwickshire county council chancellor
may i just uh uh
lodge an apology the uh the passion for
my day job which is rehabilitation i'm
afraid
he
made the automatic parking of tanks on
lawns there apologies councillor barker
but unfortunately
he's rehabilitation
noted councillor pemberton
meanwhile councillor shanton
just a very quick one uh this is a
really detailed paper i think it's
excellent it's exciting yeah it's
fantastic um and uh as a
uh hopefully um final comment i will say
congratulations on being appointed i
think congratulations i've been
appointed the chair of that committee
thank you and i wasn't completely
convinced myself
right so i see nobody else wishing to
speak so councillor barker uh i assume
that uh with your lucky four-leaf clover
you are proposing the recommendations on
page 101 i am indeed can i have a second
to please counselor kettle
all those in favor
agreed thank you
we now have a council plan monitoring
councillor cargill
thank you leader thank you members um
this is the mid-year report the
performance report 2122
you'll notice
obviously that there are still a few
items off target
but in general i've got to say this is a
good news report and i'll come to that
in a minute
we're still recovering some from some of
the issues of lockdowns pandemic etc
but i'd like to again
compliment the staff
who have responded admirably to the
challenges
prevent presented to them over the time
and i believe now we're starting to see
the organization uh getting back to on
and even here and working efficiently
you'll notice a few items in there i'm
sure we'll have a chat about some of
them
we'll start we'll still see a reduction
in both council tax and ndr
but i suppose to a certain extent that
was expected
uh some residents are still budget had
budgeting issues that we heard earlier
on
and as we reopen society more i hope
this situation will improve
uh
right reading in the detail i think this
actually this report demonstrates how we
as an organization have performed well
and society is starting to catch back up
on it and that's only to be expected i
believe
uh i recommend this to the council to
the cabinet
thank you councillor cargill uh
councillor parry and then councillor
junaid
thank you chairman i just wanted to draw
members of cabinets um
to
the
um
below target of
other planning applications determined
within eight weeks which should be 85
and it is showing in the report at 70.6
this particular figure reflects
that we still have five vacancies in
assistant planners
um and was a result of the recruitment
freeze however what i can advise members
of cabinet it the october figures which
are not incorporated into this document
show that we have
increased that back up to 83
so we're working in the right direction
and the recruitment campaign is going
well and ahead there's been a number of
internal promotions which have resulted
in
the shortfall on the assistant planners
but as i highlighted osc
whilst we
we have been continuing to look at
recruitment
we pride ourselves in bringing very
highly
highly skilled and the right make sure
that we put round pegs in round holes so
um the the work that has gone on over
the last 12 months and i think credit
needs to be
put where credit is due that our
assistant planners in particular have
been under huge pressures with the
increase of applications during the
covid pandemic with more households
putting in applications for extensions
for homeworking uh accommodation
through through your chair
through your chair do you wanna mention
about land charges
thank you thank you thank you i would
just like to say that obviously we're in
a situation where we have reduced our
land charges
right down to in fact it's actually
currently 11 days um and in august last
year it was 10 weeks which is over 50
days and that is due to a huge amount of
hard work restructuring and obviously
the transfer up to her majesty's land
registry so well done the team thank you
councillor thanks thank you councillor
parry and i have to say exceedingly well
done on the land charges and you have
reminded us that this document is
actually for the period april to
september so the update on current
numbers are
extremely useful
council unit
it's just a couple of comments on the
council plan strategic actions if you
don't mind uh page 158 cp 1c it's just a
warning when the
commentary city of culture was announced
we were told that various areas outside
commentary could benefit
so i immediately got in touch with the
officer concerned but was told that you
could only benefit if you had a cv
postcode and ulster has a b49 postcode
so i hope that that is not repeated with
the birmingham commonwealth games so
it's just a one comment there that i
hope that is on on cp3
b it talks about um stratfor town center
again could we make sure that it's
although that's welcome for stratfor
tank and center that other town centers
are also uh considered uh and may you
know the economic development and
benefit of places like ulster are also
and shipston and various other places
are all taken into account and the third
one was could we please be kept up to
date on the the fred winter center um i
i find it odd that
opening is delayed now because there has
to be additional but building safety
work on fire escapes um that's just
delayed opening
i i would have thought that that would
have come early in the process and then
and you know to hear that you know
all the work has been done and yet we're
now getting you know problems with fire
escapes uh perhaps we could have a um a
um
report on why that is
i think if i'm right uh councillor
junior the regulations changed during
construction
councillor barker
yeah change of it was um partly change
of building respects partly that they
they had different um
building control companies involved um
merely
the sort of accident accidental thing
that can happen in any project i think
i've put it down to that rather than
anything else because they come at the
end because it's the fire doors
i think the other thing is councillor
june and we are not actually managing
the development of the fred winter
center sadly not
uh yeah it is it is a joint project
we're not managing it and i would hope
that um
that given the explanation from the
portfolio holder there's no need for
anybody to start calling for another
report on it we know what the issue is
the thing will be developed as soon as
it uh delivered as soon as it can be
there was a change there have been
changes with the with the
raid companies involved
we know where we are um i'm not
convinced
there is a lot of merit in office of
time being spent on a report to tell us
what we know
i wasn't asking for a report i just
wanted to assure us yeah
fine with that then
councillor shenton
thank you leader
just a couple of quickies
cpc4c should say on page 162 um it's
showing it's not achieved we know now
that it is achieved
obviously this is a september since then
we have achieved that and just one other
quick one on the just to highlight on
the priority three of 173
the national household waste per
household
um
and we have
a performance of 95.78
kilo
per household
just so you you're aware
our performance is only bettered
slightly by warwick district council
within the warwickshire county
were actually pretty good
thank you councillor shenton
so
councillor cargill you are proposing the
recommendations
councillor kettle
cp 1c
councillor
um
in order to encourage um
residents to uh take advantage of which
burning commonwealth games i just
wondered whether you had any plans for
either councillors or even cabinet uh to
put together some sporting endeavour
to demonstrate our enthusiasm for this
uh darts by any chance
right so council cargill you're
proposing the recommendations on page
one five three can i have a second to
please
councillor shenton all those in favour
reid thank you members of cabinet
so
cabinet committee's reports are known
on block items uh
covered
these are all for noting we do have one
item of urgent business
if you just hand around the paper please
and can i have a copy
this is very simple very straightforward
uh it was on the forward plan that we do
an update on the purchase of the gateway
site this is it
um
i just draw your attention to one five
we are looking at alternative options
for required insight and addressing any
holding costs
that work is ongoing uh obviously it was
disappointing we didn't get the
uh leveling up fund
uh bid so the recommendation is
the update is received and endorsed
so uh i've proposed it councillor barca
secondly and chair
sorry uh you're taking this as an urgent
item um it's just that the uh the
requirement is for
you to determine if it is
urgent but also the reason to be
specified in the minutes i don't know
whether
tony pertz wants to comment about that
and then you can that can be recorded in
the minutes
yes i'm happy to sort of make comments
on that um i've discussed this with the
committee team that the um region for
reason for urgency using the cabinet
we're expecting sort of a report in the
forward plan which hasn't been coming
forward and in the minutes we'll be
recording it's due to sort of new
information that we've received
regarding some of the property
transaction which meant it was
inappropriate for us to bring the report
forward in full today so we're proposing
delaying that until the january
meeting of um cabinet
thank you for keeping us right mr
grafton so the update is received and
endorsed
uh members of cabinet are you happy to
receive and endorse this
agreed thank you members of cabinet
further ado
meeting closed